what's up guys so as you guys already
know in tow had been stagnant for many
years with their quad-core processors
and simply boosted the clock speed year
after year
however after eyes nose release Intel
started to feel the heat and they
released their coffee like processors
early and of course they added two cores
this move was able to help intel steal
back some market share from AMD but due
to unavailable stock and not as much
performance for the dollar many people
still stuck with rising and with the
rise into a just around the corner the
worst long from over for intone in the
past
intel has never up core count two
generations in a row but these
circumstances may be an exception due to
this the upcoming Intel i7 9700 K from
the cannon Lake series may possess eight
cores and 16 threads the i5 9600 K and I
390 350 K could also support hyper
threading just leaving it with six cores
and twelve threats for the i5 and four
course I made threats for the i3 this
would be very interesting because in
this scenario the i5 9600 K would be
just as powerful as a previous year's
flagship i7 8700 K and the i3 93 50k
would be just as good as the flagship
7700 K which is just a flagship just a
little more than a year ago it is also
expected for it to jump onto the 10
nanometer process with Intel staying on
the 40 nanometer process for many years
now so should you wait for Kenan Lake
well first let's start with the i3 93
50k I don't think this will actually
have four cores and eight threads but I
doubt Intel would want to make such a
recent processor like the 77 where k
obsolete unless rising to really bring
something to the table but that probably
won't happen if anything I believe that
the i3 may be upgraded to six cores and
six threads but honestly even then I
don't think it is worth waiting nine or
more months for the CPU because the i5
8600 K is pretty much identical to this
and not much more expensive and you can
get that right now
in tow probably will bring a new chipset
and force you to buy a new motherboard
due to the new process as a result if
you think you could save some money by
waiting for the i3 instead of buying the
i-5 right now then that's probably not
going to happen
because then the z3 70 boards will be
heavily discounted busy aren't the
flagship platform anymore
as a result an i5 8600 K plus a Z 370
motherboard n will be almost equal to
the in price and performance to a I to
be 93 50k plus as e-470 a motherboard so
I don't think there's any reason to wait
for the i3 93 50k next well the i5 9600
K have hyper threading and six cores
well this could very well happen but
again this won't really save you any
money or give you any more performance
than the current i7 8700 Cawood so I
would just recommend you to go with the
8700 K instead of waiting for nine
months
finally the 9700 K this one is the most
interesting it's really hard to what
Intel will do it especially because rice
and to hasn't come out yet in the past
we've seen that Intel likes to match or
exceed core count from their competitors
as with the skylax X series and AMD's
thread Ripper so they may want to get
eight cores onto this chip but is it
really worth waiting for that well that
really depends on your circumstances do
you really need that much power if you
are a professional user that you're
probably making money from whatever you
do like graphic design web design or
YouTube videos or whatever whatever this
may be spending some extra cash right
now could increase your productivity
right now and you will probably have
made up for the loss using your
increased productivity by just going on
to the Intel skylake X + X series
platform if you are a gamer you might as
well get the 8700 K because nowadays the
CPU is not the bottom line so two cores
won't really help you in my opinion the
only people who should wait for this are
the people who don't really need an
upgrade all of you guys are gonna wait
till the end of this year with what you
have now then you guys should definitely
consider waiting for that night in 9700
K even if it doesn't have a cork on
boost
it wouldn't really matter for you
because you weren't really sacrificing
anything by waiting for it
finally if you want to get onto ten
nanometer process then don't wait
because that really is not going to make
a difference and it's probably going to
have bugs at lunch overall I think Intel
has a great lineup right now and that
there is no real reason to wait for
Kenan Lake there will always be
something new coming out and just
because there's something better it
doesn't mean your PC is not as good
suddenly your chip will still give you
the same performance and in most cases
that's more than you will need if you're
really neat performance that you
wouldn't be watching this video you
would have just bought the chip already
as a result just go with coffee Lake if
you're starting in your build and if you
need an upgrade really badly if you
don't really need an upgrade then maybe
consider waiting for Kenlake or even
just until risin - which is a much
smaller weight if you guys are
interested in if you should wait for
rising - then make sure to click on link
in description below and check out my
video on that as well well guys that's
all I have for you guys this time if you
guys liked it make sure you drop a like
on this video I really like to see what
you guys are thinking so make sure to
post us in the comments down below and
if you haven't subscribed already make
sure to subscribe hit that Bell
notification if you would like to see
more videos just like this but that's
all I have for you guys this time and
until next video bye